we are sending them to the united states
capital where the body administration
will be able to more immediately address
the needs of the people that they are
allowing to come across our border
texas governor greg abbott has a new
plan to handle the growing surge of
migrants that are entering his state
illegally and overwhelming local
communities you see it reported here
every day in addition to other measures
the state will begin sending migrants on
charter buses directly to washington
dropping them off at the steps of the
u.s capitol governor abbott joins us now
from austin texas and i know that you
are incredibly frustrated that the
federal government is not doing its job
in order to protect the border you've
committed state resources to do that a
congresswoman from your state sheila
jackson lee she had thoughts about your
proposal listen here
acts of hysteria and grandstanding
national guard at the border
to the extent that they're committing
suicide
now announcement of massive buses
of migrants that may be coming across
and i think either sending them i saw
the word washington i wasn't sure
whether they said washington dc
washington state those are not problem
solving
those are just creating the grand march
of hysteria
tell us more about your plan and also i
understand that there's a press release
that was issued later last night that
explained that the migrants would have
to volunteer to get on a bus to go to
washington dc is that right
well let me explain how this whole
process works first the the big goal
that we're seeking to achieve and that
is joe biden has refused to come to the
border to see the chaos that he has
created by his open border policies so
we're going to take the border to him by
uh transporting the the people that he
is dropping off in these local
communities in the state of texas and
sending them to washington by plane or
by bus uh what was happening is uh
there's an increased number of people
coming across the border that they the
federal government are processing and
then letting loose and what has been
happening so far is those people will be
getting on buses and going to san
antonio
or or houston or other places like that
and so i think they just need longer bus
rides uh with with regard to uh the
voluntary component of it understand
this uh and that is uh dana if i were to
go to washington dc uh and take you and
put you on a bus and take you down to
the rio grande valley that would be
kidnapping same thing applies to anybody
who refuses to get onto a bus that would
be kidnapping even though it would be by
a law enforcement agency so there are
laws that have to be found on this
process that said i can tell you this
overnight
there were multiple communities in the
rio grande valley that have been in
communication with their office
asking us to provide buses for them
maybe even planes to provide for them
for the movement of these migrants
listen these migrants once they come
across the border it's not as if they
want to stay down there in the rio
grande valley as you have already
reported previously they're moving
across the entire country as they move
across the entire country what better
place for them to go to than the steps
of the united states capital they're
going to see the wonderful capital but
also get closer to the people who are
making these policies that are allowing
people to come across the border
illegally so governor in summary then
you will make the offer and it's up to
them to say yes or no to get on board
that bus
and
bill here's the deal this has been
happening
for weeks if not months now so we know
the process already works uh it's just a
matter of uh relocating the the drop-off
point as opposed to san antonio or
houston or some other place uh as you
also know uh the bite administration has
been transporting these people across
the country the same principle applies
for the about administration they they
can't be kidnapping people that they've
authorized to be in the united states
legally they have to get their
permission to move them across the
united states also
and so this is something that we know
there's high demand for already and we
will be fulfilling that demand by
putting these people on buses and planes
and taking them to washington dc
understood on that i don't know what
more you can do with security at the
border perhaps there's a state issue
there that you could flush out there but
with regard to title 42 about a month
and a half away now it seems like this
ball's up in the air we talked to tom
cotton two hours ago and senator mark
kelly from arizona he wants more answers
on this there's a number of democrats
around the bubble for being reelected in
november
apparently there were some concerns with
them as well i i
joe manchin is is is not on board now
there's kirsten cinema from arizona it
kind of seems like there might be some
wiggle room as to whether or not
congress can push back on the idea that
that title 42 would be revoked in late
may
well your spot on this and the fact of
the matter is this is a bipartisan issue
because both republicans and democrats
realize the chaos the by administration
has caused the inhumanity of what the
administration has caused i've heard
rumors there may be a what's called a
discharge petition uh in the u.s house
of representatives it would require a
vote on this uh and you may see the same
thing on the senate side listen everyone
realizes let me give you this
astonishing number according to the
department of homeland security they are
expecting after title 42 is removed to
have as many as 18 000 people come
across the border a day uh if you
calculate that out on an annual basis
that's going to be more than 5 million
people coming across the border
illegally every year and those will be
the ones apprehended and so this clearly
is unprecedented it's a high volume that
the united states and states like texas
are ill-equipped to be able to deal with
uh and the bad administration has no
idea about the chaos is stoked you think
that americans are angry about inflation
right now wait till they see the chaos
that's going to occur on the border
because of biden's open border policies
and it really hurts those who are trying
to go through the process legally
because everything else gets backed up
thank you governor abbott we appreciate
you coming on this thank you sir
thank you all thank you hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now